DJ Durkin returning return I cannot
believe that this guy's coaching
Maryland football again and that the
president who back in August said that
the school accepted responsibility
legally and morally for the death of
this young man
Jordan McNair that that this president
Wallace LOH now is saying he's retiring
and the Board of Regents apparently
threatened to fire him if he did not
retire and let them reinstall DJ Dirk
and his head coach crazy so Washington
Post columnist berries for lugar here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you berry
great did I get that right is this is
this in fact what happened that the team
that the president the school president
accepted responsibility in August and
the Board of Regents got hold of this
thing and totally reversed course is
that what happened essentially yeah I
mean it still is my brain is scrambled
on this I mean every time I hear the
facts laid out it's and then it
concludes with DJ Durkin will coach
Maryland's football team against
Michigan State on Saturday I my jaw kind
of falls to the floor again yes well
most of all the president of the
University of Maryland at College Park
expect accepted legal and moral
responsibility in in August as they
placed DJ Durkin on leaves the Board of
Regents which oversees all of Maryland
state schools then took the control of
two different investigations one on the
medical procedures and two on the
culture that these judges included from
took it away from College Park which at
the time seems kind of reasonable
because you don't want the people they
are making judgments on their own I can
I can understand that but it got
backwards and it ended with the Regents
telling Wallace LOH that if he wanted to
keep his job even until the end of the
academic year that they had to put DJ
Durkin back in place as the head
football coach in damon.evans back as
the athletic director
it's it's a disgrace I mean he DJ Durkin
created an environment in a football
program that fostered a way of going
about things that allow Jordan McNair to
die he was struggling completing sprints
and instead of being identified as
somebody who needed help in the moment
he was identified as a weakness
Marilyn did not have in place basic best
practices to keep Jordan McNair alive
this was a preventable death and it
happened on DJ Durkins watch and he got
paid through all of August and September
in October and he will coach the tokens
on Saturday and that is astonishing so
before we get to the why here I still
want to get into the reasoning as to the
why that was presented by James Brady
the University Board of Regents chairman
is it am I to understand the reason why
DJ Durkin is not to be held fully
responsible is because of whatever was
going on that caused Kevin Anderson the
previous athletic director to take a
six-month professional development
sabbatical after which he left
putting damon.evans who has his own
history at Georgia in to this position
of athletic director and that
dysfunction is something that didn't
allow DJ Durkin to do what am i right in
that to that sound you're totally right
I mean I mean where to start on on that
yes DJ Durkin in part has his job back
because the report that the region's
kind of commissioned concluded that
there was so much dysfunction in the
athletic department that it was very
confusing as the cool reported to who so
the strength clues my Court is now out
and was out the day these reports
initially came came out who Durkin hired
correct who brought him was his first
hire correct
and pollutants got into was that it
wasn't clear who reported to what didn't
you break I mean Rick these are Durkin
was quoted in the Washington Post a year
ago saying the head coach and a strength
coach have to be on the same page I'm
paraphrasing here they have to be on the
same page or the whole program doesn't
look Rick Kourt and I are completely on
the same page what else need to know in
that report can't be discrete cohere
because these are doping is yeah you
know allowing him and embolden him gate
the environment that the Regents found
flawed and so they also said in this in
throwing their conclusions that DJ
Durkin who they're paying two point five
million dollars a year and has worked
his whole life to become a head football
coach was not properly mentored in
warning how to run a Big Ten football
program give me another good live in my
er he looked for Jim Harbaugh he worked
at Ford she's been around
he needs a buddy system in order to
figure out what's right and wrong in
order to figure out what's complete and
inappropriate that that's another joke
in a long list of jokes in this whole
berries for luga of the Washington Post
columnist here on the Rich Eisen show ok
so now they were I think I lost track of
the Gimme a Break s-- from you and I
have lost track in my mind as well of
the it's so difficult I literally spent
a half an hour 45 minutes hour before
the show trying to get all my facts
straight for this conversation and for
my my my reasoning that I gave in the
hour and the first hour to make sure
that if this is all straight and it's so
convoluted and it's absolutely so mind
bogglingly confusing why would the Board
of Regents go through all of this
gymnastics but you know obviously a
figurative fur DJ Durkin to return him
to the sidelines when they know what it
will affect in terms of recruiting in
the campus and they also know what it
would mean
maybe into that locker room right now
why do it what's the what is the reason
money is it liability what is it Barry
well so that there is a crass line of
thinking I think it has to realistically
address that money is probably a factor
here I mean I am I'm gonna try to tie
together two seemingly unrelated things
here because this is so confusing I hope
you'll follow along Maryland less the
Atlantic Coast Conference it's home for
so many years and the place where so
many of its fans identified with they
have their rivals they knew who they
were they won a national championship
under Gary Williams they had a football
program under another alum Ralph ragin
that they could be proud of they left
for the Big Ten because they were so
financially strapped they said that they
needed they essentially needed the money
and I would argue that when they left
for the Big Ten they'd lost their
identity they lost their way I'm not
saying that the move to the Big Ten
killed Jordan McNair but I think you can
stitch together a line of thinking that
they needed to make decisions based on
financial realities and that put them in
a position where a DJ Durkin character
is running a program in which its own
administration that infighting is not
overseeing the program properly they're
chasing in their own division in the Big
Ten
Ohio State Penn State and Michigan which
realistically they have no business
fighting with on a week-to-week or
ear-to-ear basis in the sport of
football they don't have the facilities
they don't the money they don't have the
history they don't have the tradition to
keep up with that with that lot and then
you get to a point where if they feel
legally they can't fire DJ Durkin with
cause the buyout is north of five
million and and that the University of
Maryland athletics department at this
point is a lot of money Kevin Plank the
founder of Under Armour and a former
football player could write that check
if he wanted to it tells me that Kevin
Plank was not on board with DJ Durkin
being out and must have been on board
with DJ Durkin being in
or he wouldn't be the coach at Maryland
anymore no kidding Wow so that's the
money aspect of it Barry is varuga of
the Washington Post columnist here and
the Rich Eisen show so what what happens
now Barry I mean the pleasure couple
players walked out we're seeing on on
social media they do not accept him as
their coach and there's gonna be a
demonstration on campus Wallace Lowe
just to make sure that I get it all out
here asked if it came down if it did
come down to Dirk under him his full
response was quote I've accepted the
recommendations in full of the Board of
Regents which sounds like something out
of The Manchurian Candidate so what
happens here Barry is you know it's so
amazing that you figured the decision on
the football coach and the athletics
director would be the end and the start
of something new and and because they've
left everybody in the same positions and
that infrastructure of the department
and the school is the exact same as it
was when Jordan McNair died in a way I
think we're just beginning it remains to
be seen how many players will will show
up and play on Saturday against Michigan
State it remains to be seen how DJ
Durkin staff feels about this entire
operation I think we haven't heard you
know we're starting to hear from the
leadership of the state of Maryland I
think some heavy-hitter voices like Tom
McMillan the former all-american
basketball player at Maryland who's long
been an operative in in state and US
politics a former House of
Representatives member you you were
probably waiting to hear from from those
people but you know at what point is it
an appropriate question for DJ Durkin
hey it's third and six you know what do
you feel like Kasim Hills best ability
as a roll out passer is in that
situation when is that ever going to be
appropriate to ask him basic football
questions it's too big at this point and
it might be too but even though he's
been reinstated it really might be too
big for him to win back his own team win
back incoming
that's a whole separate story how could
you how could a five-star recruit that
has options listen to this guy in his
living room and say I know you could go
to Penn State I know you could go to
Georgia I know you could go to Clemson
Maryland is right for you
how did you win even one of those
arguments when does he speak what is he
easy you know we're hoping and I think
it would do them some good to have him
speak at some point before the Michigan
State game but that might not happen
then we'll see what happened after was
that all of this is fluid and like I
said in some ways the story gets fresh
legs today and start to do rather than
coming to a close and and does does
James Brady the Board of Regents
Chairman feel like okay so we're gonna
implement all of the recommendations of
the findings of the investigation and
the one who's gonna implement them is
the same coach and the same athletic
director and we're good you know what's
so we're done let's that's so let's go
beats party like is he really does that
guy really think that for real it defies
it defies logic and and that's why I
think this it's important now to to not
make this about the problems in the
Maryland football program or the
infighting in the Maryland athletic
department this is a stain on the
university as a whole because the people
that oversee it thought that fundamental
change was needed and whether they want
to parse the definition of toxic or say
you know DJ Durkin hadn't created a
quote toxic culture they are pinning
their hopes and pinning their future to
a guy that is fundamentally flawed and
and don't let damon.evans off here
either I mean his job before he was the
interim athletic director was to
directly oversee football he was either
willfully ignorant of what was going on
there or didn't care
knew the practices that Durkin was
putting in place but thought they were
appropriate
it was so caught up with the infighting
and backstabbing with his boss Kevin
Anderson that he was distracted or some
of all three of those
and to put him back into place to lead
an athletic director that I'm sorry an
athletic department that needs a full-on
turnaround is is an extension of the
sick joke
I really am astonished that we're having
these conversations today and just to
make sure just last one for you Barry
just to make sure cuz I want to make
sure we're buttoned up fair balanced
however you want to put it there are
some players and and and Regents and
boosters and and players who are pro
Durkin right it's not like it's the
entire student body and and locker room
against him right he has some supporters
I'd love to what's is he a nice guy a
good guy I mean like trying to figure
out what what where that comes from well
yeah I mean I think it is important to
note that not only some players are
supportive but but some players families
are supportive and that's that's
important to note I mean I I believe
this is a black and white issue but I
understand why why people people don't
because if he's some evil how would any
of the of the players support and my
question would be you know there there
are two sides to every argument how many
is too many players and players families
who thought the environment was
ill-suited and and and really kind of
sick before you say we have to remove
this guy I don't think that this is one
that should be a straight vote and the
majority just carries the day I think
that DJ Durkin was in a position that he
had proved that he was a unifier not a
divider and I think there are things in
that in that report and things in the
reporting that my colleagues have done
in terms of how he created a caste
system of half and half moment and
really tried to run people off from from
the team if he thought they weren't
contributing I think that there's enough
there that even with support from
significant people he should not be in
the position that he's returning to
today well berries for luga of the
Washington Post know this we we looked
over the last 24 hours is our staff and
our Booker's and it's like who's the
person who can come from the
mid-atlantic region who's covered this
who can give voice and let everybody
know what's going on there and alums and
people who are fellow colleagues of
yours and are in our business all said
you it all pointed towards you so we
appreciate you calling in thanks I
appreciate every bet that's Barry's for
luga of the Washington Post and look I
know DJ Durkin may have his supporters
and the parents and I know I'm just
surfing into this I'm on an alum I'm not
I know I'm just dropping in on this
story but to those folks it could have
been your kid easily could have been
your kid who had trouble with
conditioning that day the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience